the golden shower the story is is it's
kind of a classic journalistic ethical
dilemma on the one hand what do you do
about a new story that everybody's
talking about but whose factual basis is
suspect you know as a news organization
you can't really ignore it but if you
cover it at all you're giving it
attention without confirming it which is
kind of not what we're supposed to do in
this business people who go to
journalism school or have been in this
business for a long time we're kind of
inculcated with this idea of the malice
standard right we're not supposed to put
anything out there that we know to be
untrue or that we we don't feel solid
about if we knowingly put something out
there in the news that we are unsure of
the nets that's malice right that's
worse that's that's the grounds for
libel that's what we're not supposed to
do that's what the law tells us
affirmative ly that we can't do but
that's exactly what went on with this
BuzzFeed story they actually openly said
in the story we have doubts about the
veracity of this material we're gonna
put it out there anyway and so now what
does everybody do you can't put the
genie back in the bottle now it's a new
story it's a phenomenon that everybody's
talking about but but if we can't
confirm what's in the actual dossier
then how do we talk about it none and
there's an additional problem with this
story which is that the motives of
almost everybody involved are suspect
how is this material getting to
reporters well we know for sure that it
was being shopped around to a number of
different journalists in the last five
to six months it started off as
opposition research first in the
Republican Party and then by the
Democrats and then there's this other
problem where there are these these
leaks that are emanating from the
intelligence services that are trying to
foist I think on the population this
idea that there are links between Russia
and Vladimir Putin between Russia and
Donald Trump but they're doing it in a
way without showing their hand as to
what the evidence is for therefore that
belief you know it's somebody who lived
over there for a long time the dossier
reads like the inside of the Kremlin
it's like a high school cafeteria where
you can overhear all these amazing state
secrets all the time I mean that's just
not the point
operate they run a much tighter ship
than that in my experience III don't
remember ever hearing anybody leaking
word of you know these these
conversations between Putin and his
inner circle it's just really really
hard for me to imagine that we would get
anything out of out of the Kremlin that
they didn't want us to have which makes
it more confusing you know is this a
disinformation campaign that's coming
from Russia or is it totally fabricated
by whoever wrote up that dossier or are
the intelligence services trying to make
us think that it's true I mean it's it's
it's a it's a very difficult thing to
try to sort out but that's exactly the
kind of thing we shouldn't be doing is
journalist is engaging in this guessing
game we don't we should really just
stick to what we know
it is it's exactly it's like a bad
parody of a avila carry a novel or
something like that yeah
you